simple secret la sortie demain d'un
premier film d'un jeune réalisateur
américain consacré à un thème très à la
mode en ce moment au cinéma une histoire
de famille et une distribution
exceptionnelle l'occasion aussi de
découvrir un leonardo dicaprio avant les
faits titanic est plutôt convaincant
dominique poncet et georges milan doit
percer mais ce sont deux soeurs deux
soeurs qui vont se retrouver après de
longues années de fâcherie parce que
l'une atteinte de leucémie a besoin de
la moelle épinière de l'autre des
retrouvailles seront rudes car la malade
joué par diane keaton est une sorte de
saintes qui a passé sa vie à s'occuper
des autres
alors que sa soeur est une égoïste
hystérique un rôle étonnant pour la
douce mélopée à l'afp ce proche ça m'a
bien plu de jouer ce personnage parce
qu'il m'a permis d'exorciser tous mes
démons et tout mais colère intérieure
et puis j'ai toujours été attiré dans
des rôles de femme complexe où on peut
inventer des réactions violentes face à
mary street
il y a dans une diane keaton qu'on
n'avait jamais vu non plus comme cela
éblouissante d'humanité mon personnage
est une femme qui a tout perdu même la
santé parce qu'elle a tout donné et cela
apparemment de l'humanité de la famille
le jouer ça a été vraiment une
expérience bouleversante car je n'avais
jamais connu de personne qui ait une
telle trempe de caractère en cinq actes
simples secret et tant qu'unique longer
dans l'intimité d'une famille
c'est poignant parce que la maladie road
mais c'est passionnant aussi parce que
la vie y est racontée de façon décalée
quand j'ai lu le script la première fois
j'ai pas du moins c'est un film
les dialogues étaient si vrai en même
temps bourré d'humour
bref c'était comme du cinéma c'était
comme la vie d' aller voir ce film pour
les acteurs évidemment tous sensationnel
mais aussi pour la belle leçon
d'humanité qui s'en dégage